واحنا واقفين ما فيش اي مشكله في المعدي
بيتمشى هو وصاحبه في النهر وفي راينو هناك
قاعد نايم حاجه جميله والله
[موسيقى]
تجربه التجول الحري دي كانت تجربه مختلفه
جدا بالنسبه لي وكانت اول مره اعملها مش
زي السفاري العاديه مش بتبقى راكبين مثلا
عربيه وبنتمشى وسط طريق معروف قوي وعمالين
بنحاول نبص حوالينا يمين وشمال عشان نلاقي
حيوانات
ولكن الموضوع بيبقى مختلف شويه ان احنا
بقى بنتمشى بالراحه جدا معظم الوقت
بينبهوا علينا ان احنا مثلا نلبس لبس اخضر
او حاجات مشابهه لالوان الشجر اللي هو
مثلا بني او حاجه بحيث اللبس بتاعنا يبقى
كانه كامه فلاش كده او كان بيبقى مختلطين
مع الطبيعه اللي حوالينا ونفضل على مهلنا
نتمشى نحاول نلاقي حيوانات سواء بقى مثلا
ثعابين سوا سواحف سواء وحيد القرن اللي
لقيناه حوالي مرتين او ثلاث مرات واحنا
بنتمشى
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه نايم نايم هناك
وحيد القرن تحديدا ممكن يبقى خطر شويه لو
احنا قربنا منه
على طول يعني بيدي زي انذار قبل لما يبتدي
يهجم فبيبتدي ان هو يبص في عينينا الاول
ويحرك زي رجليه الاتنين اللي قدام كده
كانه بيدي تحذير لو احنا ما استجمناش
للتحذير ده وقربنا اكتر ممكن فعلا يبتدي
ان هو يجري علينا ويكذب علينا بسرعه شديده
جدا وسهله عليه قوي ان هو يسبقنا وبيسبق
البني ادمين بكل سهوله وبيقتل فعلا ناس
كتيره اصلا في المنطقه بتاعه
معنا بيكونوا مستعدين طبعا لان لو حصل
حاجه لا قدر الله ان هم ياخذوا بالهم من
الناس اللي موجوده وبيبقى في برضه يعني
ارشادات معينه بيقولوها لنا قبل ما احنا
بنتحرك لو ما حدش يا جماعه يخرج بره
البريل اللي احنا ماشيين فيه لازم نمشي
ورا بعض بالظبط نمشي بالراحه ما نبصش
للحيوانات ساعات في عينيها يعني مثلا زي
القرود مش المفروض ان احنا نبص في عينين
القرد على طول لان كان بيحس ان احنا كاننا
اللي هو داخلين معاه منافسه فممكن يبتدي
ان هو يهاجمنا او حاجه نفس الكلام بالنسبه
الوحيده تقارن لان حصلت اصلا لينا كانت
وحيد قرن نشوفه فعلا ادانا انذار واضطرينا
ان احنا نرجع بسرعه جدا عشان كان لو
اتمشينا شويه كمان كان هيهجم علينا هو جاي
ورانا اهو بيتحرك بالراحه بس احنا لازم
نمشي الناس يعني اتفاجات خالص من ان
الكلام ده اصلا موجود فين برده في ناس
بترعبت جدا من حته التجول المفتوح كان
الناس تخضت بطريقه جامده جدا لان هم حسوا
بخطوه قد ايه الموضوع ممكن يبقى خطير لو
طلع لنا نمبر هنعمل ايه ولكن بالنسبه لي
الموضوع بيبقى احلى بكثير قوي ان احنا
نشوف الحيوانات دي في الفئه الطبيعيه
بتاعتها مش في حديقه حيوانه او كده انا
بحب شغل الحيوانات في المكان الطبيعي
بتاعها